Salut peuple de l'internet qui regarde des vidéos sur internet.
En ce début de semaine, c'est pas du tout cette vidéo qui était prévue pour
aujourd'hui. Mais j'ai eu une idée ce week end et je vous avoue que je suis en mode
obsessionnel depuis trois jours là-dessus, sûr une nouvelle méthode qui permettrait de retenir des longues séquences de chiffres. Alors longue, tout est relatif,
mais ça pourrait être par exemple pour retenir un code à 30 chiffres. Je ne sais pas pourquoi, mais dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
je divaguais et un peu (peut-être à cause de tout ce fromage à raclette que je mange en ce moment !) et je me suis dit :
quand je retiens des séquences de chiffres.
Par exemple, si vous suivez la chaîne ou que vous êtes procuré mon livre, vous savez que tous les ans, je mémorise un code à
12 chiffres qui me permet de savoir quel jour de la semaine tombe n'importe quelle date de l'année. Je vous mets d'ailleurs la vidéo qu'on
avait faite avec un Amixem sur le sujet ici. Il y a  deux solutions pour mémoriser ce genre de séquence : soit vous utilisez une technique, comme
celle que je vous expliquais, de la table de rappel, du palais mental ou de visualisation, ce qui va vous permettre de retenir
l'intégralité mais dans un ordre précis.
C'est-à-dire, vous êtes obligé de passer par le début pour pouvoir après tout enfiler. Vous ne pouvez pas accéder à l'une des
informations à un placement précis.
Avec une table de rappel c'est possible, mais c'est un petit peu lourd pour faire juste ça. Soit, vous faites comme moi vous séquencez,
c'est-à-dire que ce code à douze chiffres, je l'imagine en 4 codes à trois chiffres.
Quand je dis j'imagine, c'est au sens littéral : dans ma tête j'ai un bloc un bloc, un bloc, un bloc et c'est des petits
blocs de trois. Si je cherche le septième, je sais que c'est le premier du troisième bloc,
vous voyez, l'idée. Là justement, je suis en train d'apprendre mon code pour l'année prochaine.
Je préfère me mettre à jour tous les ans même si un même code peut durer quatre ans. Et c'est là
qu'il y a eu un truc bizarre là dedans. Je sais pas pourquoi, aucune idée, mais j'ai pensé aux partitions des musiciens. Vous savez, les partitions
les tablatures de guitare par exemple, soit les
partitions classiques pour mettre ça clé de sol, de fa, de bien, de ce que tu veux. Ca fait Fabien, jeu de mots !
Et dans l'idée, je me suis dit est ce qui serait pas plus performant de
visualiser ces blocs de chiffres, ces séquences là, dans la deuxième méthode dont je vous parlais, mais en les mettant sur des lignes différentes. Vous voyez,
là par exemple mettre 342, 757,
338, etc. Je viens d'essayer pour une partie des décimales de Pi, oui je sais, je m'éclate !
Eh bien ça marche beaucoup mieux . Parce que vous savez que j'essaie d'apprendre Pi
le plus possible. Alors ça, ça va, j'utilise des palais mentaux, un peu de synesthésie,
j'ai ma méthodologie pour ça. Je vous avais fait une vidéo sur le sujet, vous avez le lien
ici. Mais pour les séquencer, c'est plus compliqué. Et là pour les séquencer, c'est mortel : ça va 3, 4 fois plus vite !
Enfin j'ai l'impression d'une beaucoup plus performant. De le même manière, j'ai appri mon code pour l'année prochaine comme ça,
en un claquement de doigts. Dans ma tête, je l'ai rangé comme ça, sans faire d'image pour retenir les chiffres, c'est juste les données
brutes, en les plaçant comme ça et en les visualisant. Ca s'est accroché
direct ! Ca s'est
accroché dans ma tête. Depuis deux jours, je fais des recherches sur le net je demande à des gens qui s'y connaissent en mémoire et
mnémotechnique. Personne n'a entendu parler d'une méthode comme ça donc c'est une piste que je lance, voilà. Ca m'est venu il y a quelques jours.
Si ça vous dit de creuser avec moi là dessus, de voir ce qui est possible,
d'essayer de vous en servir et de voir s'il en sort n'hésitez pas à me faire vos retours par mail, vous avez mon mail
dans la description, toujours. Et on pourrait voir comment utiliser ça. Je sens bien, en fait, qu'il y a quelque chose d'encore plus
intéressant à faire avec ça, mais j'ai l'impression d'avoir créé un outil, comme un marteau mais
j'ai pas encore tous les clous qui existent que je pourrais utiliser avec. Vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
En tout cas, je trouve ça génial si le fait d'avoir fait des vidéos avec vous, pendant un peu plus d'un an et demi,
ça me permet aussi de créer de nouvelles méthodes et nouvelles pistes sur la sur la mémoire.
Ma foi, c'est formidable ! Donc si vous avez des sources sur le sujet, peut-être que ça existe déjà,
faites-en moi part. Si vous vous en servez  et que vous vous rendez compte que c'est plus simple pour vous pour faire autre chose, que
vous avez une utilisation de l'idée de la partition mentale, vous pouvez m'en faire part et puis si vous avez juste des idées
que moi je pourrais creuser de mon côté... Genre "ouais mais avec ça, je me dis que tu pourrais faire ça, ça, ça..."
Vous me le dites dans les commentaires et
on fera une suite à tout ça. Moi je me pencherai sur le sujet, c'est ma petite passion du moment.
Je pense que je vais être focus là dessus pendant un mois !
N'oubliez pas de liker, de vous abonner si vous découvrez la chaîne pour la première fois, et
rendez-vous en fin de semaine. En temps normal,
la vidéo sur le vendredi mais là il y a une petite particularité donc ce ne sera que pour ce week-end. Et je vous embrasse !
Ciao !
[musique]